draft on everyone and I think before we
start off because the internet is
intermittent you you can start cloning
the repo and by the time we get into
hands-on I think everyone should have
most of it there it's github.com / unity
hyphen XYZ / intro to deep learning for
NLP okay let me create a shorter you are
oh yeah okay
yeah so it's small dot cat / pig and
I'll redirect a repository yeah and just
rewrite you guys there any constructing
the repo meanwhile we get started yeah
hi Bob so i'm nichelle and he's i got
them and we are co-founders and data
scientist at unity data labs i'm coming
this okay I don't know the data labs and
we do data science consulting for
various companies in bangalore and today
we're here talking about introduction to
deep learning and we'll see how deep
learning is being used in the field of
natural language processing so before I
get started and start going deeper how
many of you here know what deep learning
is all about and neural networks okay
yeah then I might bo you guys a little
bit because i'll be talking to about
some introduction on what deep learning
is and how it started and what's the
inspiration so today's agenda is we'll
start looking at motivation to learning
introduction to artificial neural
networks and MLP and then hands-on on
the MLP and we start looking at how deep
learning is being used in the field of
natural language processing first okay
so before we go into deep learning how
many of you here are familiar with
machine learning Wow okay awesome okay
so this cartoon probably explains it all
right and there's a boss who says an
internet is telling him that he might be
dumb enough to enjoy extreme sports and
he goes to his employee and he says the
Internet's trying to kill me and he says
this is what we call data sign it OH
machine learning okay machine learning
is extracting features from data to
solve predictive tasks right and what
are the use cases so we've all of us
have used amazon all of us use credit
cards and
learnings widely being used to build
recommendation systems it's being used
for forecasting it's trying to capture
anomalies and yeah today we're not here
to talk about machinery so this is what
it does the reason I bring this up is a
will break the words into two halves
what exactly is learning anyone what
what is learning like when someone says
it's machine learning or this here
talking about deep learning what exactly
is learning sorry extracting rules for
solving a problem right so let's go even
more trivial how many of you can
recognize all the digits here everybody
yeah all of us can because irrespective
of how fives return or seven is written
we can understand what this is but now
if I were to make a system understand
this and ask the system if I give you a
number can you tell me what it is it
probably can so this is how you do it
you have an input you build a
mathematical model and then it gives you
an output now then you start using
functions and you compute whatever works
and you start using the ones that work
for you so here the simplest one
probably be something like k-means where
you're saying if i give you a number
give me the one that it's more similar
to but the problem here is now there are
so many different ways you can write a
number and if you were to put all of
them into one single model the mall
starts to break the reason being hard
cold hard coded rules are very brittle
the model in turn is not actually
learning it's just understanding the
rules that you've provided the model and
it's trying to show you results that
might not be very accurate and yeah so
let's look at how what is the biological
inspiration for learning right and okay
so how many of you guys
here have heard of the terms cognitive
science or neuroscience okay so before
going there how many of you have seen
small kids grow up right everywhere so I
think the biggest thing that all of us
try to do before we even understand any
of this is we try to think only
mathematically or in a computational way
without even trying to understand what
is the inspiration for building neural
networks what is the main idea why
neural networks work and the biggest
influence has been biological
inspiration where neural network is
nothing but we are trying to recreate
the neurons that are triggering through
a mind and a neuron actually consists of
a soma which is essentially you're my
your mathematical function and then
there's inputs that are coming through
your dendrites and the outcomes are
going through the axon so in our body we
are able to assimilate all of this at
such high speeds with so much accuracy
because they're about 10 to the power of
love in neurons that are working right
now as I speak probably more because I'm
on stage and and each of them are
connected to the other neurons like the
100,000 synapses that go out of each
neuron okay so the next biggest question
we have is a as we've as we are growing
up we've learned so much and it's
fascinating that we can remember so much
of it and base our decisions on top of
that so how do we actually you know
detect information and how do we store
it and using this how does it influence
our recognition of its if you've seen
kids grow up even before kids hit school
they're already talking or grammatically
write sentences they're able to detect
the difference between drinking water
drinking water and the ocean and you
know what's what and you've never really
you see you don't sit with a kid and
tell them you know what this is what
this is how you should speak this is
these are the words that you need to
pick
up but the kids already learning and the
main reason is a it's looking at its
surroundings it's trying to understand
what people are talking about and
internally the learning mechanism kicks
in where it knows that it doesn't know
that there's grammar associated with its
speech but it knows that this is the
right way of doing things so let's let's
take a little more deeper on how our
visual cortex actually works and how you
guys are able to see this and you're not
scared or that this is a demon or
something that's coming or the main
reason is first there's a hierarchy
that's in place and that we are not
aware of because the neurons are so fast
and they're working at such speeds that
you don't really think your minds
actually doing this but what actually
happens is you your visual cortex breaks
down systems into first identifying the
edges and once the edges are identified
it tries to understand the position in
the place of an object through its shape
and slowly differentiates befits a cat
or dog but it's so fast that you don't
really see that this is happening so in
short hierarchy is very important and
the complex output comes from building
small things first yeah and the examples
of learning so let's take a very simple
example right two curves on a plane arm
so if I were to give you guys a point
how would you classify the point to be
on the blue line on the red line how
would any of you guys do it
sorry distance from ya so you would
probably have a threshold you would have
a threshold anything that's greater than
zero is on the blue region and thing
that's lesser than zero is on the red
one how many of you are happy with this
how many of you are happy that if you
have a system that does this you're okay
with it none okay let's make it a little
better let's try to give it shape all
right and we say anything that is of
this shape that comes in and I show it
in the blue region and the one in the
red how am I actually doing this l any
of you have any idea how this happens
how we have a model that can sit against
the lines of the curve oh yeah
mathematically up mathematical yeah so
uh instead of going yeah and so going
says simple thing is we are able to
linearly separate two regions and how do
we do that is we we transform it to a
higher dimension in the sense we look at
a dimension where we can linearly
separate two things and we say this is
the model that fits and this is what I'm
going to use now this works and this is
beautiful because in two-dimensional
space and you can solve this but in a
real world okay so this is a
visualization of okay I know why it's
not playing okay okay I'm sorry there's
just not playing but what it tries to
show us it tries to show how if you have
two curves and the visualization of how
you can linearly separate them now what
would you do with this it's no more in
two dimension it's no more on XY plane
and this really becomes very hard to
solve not that it can't be solved but
this is how a real world problems are
what we learn from books is most of it's
just on an XY plane and you try to build
models and mathematical formulas around
it but in a real world when you start
working with things like this this is
when things become more and more tricky
I'll not get into how you can solve this
there is a beautiful post returned by
Cola Christopher Ola on how you can
solve this and he's given a lot of neat
descriptions on how you separate them
and what is what is the process that's
more about the biological inspiration
and why we have neural networks raag
atomic let's talk about how neural
networks are built and what are the
building blocks and after that we look
at MLP yeah so this will showed us how
the biological law inspiration of
artificial neural networks are by
audible yeah ok so let us try to use the
same thing and model simple neural
network and see how artificial neural
networks actually worked what are the
building blocks of that so before we go
there a simple question a zebra sorry
yeah is it the black with the white
stripes or white with black stripes
black and white stripes ok and what do
you guys say you think it's right black
with white stripes are white with black
stripes so no she's right it's black
with white stripes
okay so going back to the building
blocks of artificial neural networks we
saw the soma dendrites of our brain and
how it functions so we model our neural
network also in the same way so we have
the neurons all the circles here are
neurons and then each neuron is
connected to other neurons wire
connection which was basically the axons
and dendrites in our brain and every
neuron does some function and this is
called as an activation function so it
receives an input or a set of inputs
does some transformation and gives you
an output yeah and to do any complex set
of activities let's say recognizing a
digit a simple neuron cannot do and
learn everything there so what we do is
we build a cluster of neurons and
connect them together so this is our
simple neural network looks like you
have a set of inputs and then you have a
hidden layer which has activation
functions which actually transform the
input to output and give you the output
here yeah so this is actually called a
feed-forward Network so the include is
always flowing from the data is always
flowing from left to right but it never
comes back there is no feedback loop
here if you see so this is called a
feed-forward neural network and you can
have multiple set of hidden layers that
can be two or more not just one so what
are these activation functions actually
so you get an input you transform you
have a mathematical function you
transform it and it is an output so
there are different activation functions
out there and the first or the earliest
one is the perceptron so here you define
a threshold and any value any input
value below the threshold is zero
and a value above the threshold is one
so it does simple to us it will just
tell you 0 or 1 and then we have sigmoid
or the logistic function which we have
most of us are aware of we just get a
value between 0 and 1 and you can use
this as a probability and let's say you
want to do a multi-class problem then
you don't have one output but you have
multiple outputs let's say we are
detecting you have a photo and then you
want the neural network model to tell
you if it is a cat or a dog or sparrow
something so you have multiple classes
there so that is when you use soft mark
it is basically a generalization of
logistic regression or seek point then
the next one is a more simple one
rectified linear unit or it's called as
rail you so what he what do you do here
is you have a threshold any value below
the threshold is zero any value above
the threshold is the input value itself
so if our threshold is let's say minus 2
and the input is minus 3 the output will
be 0 and if your input is for now total
before so that's about value and again
we have a generalization of rail you as
well which is called max out so if you
see here let's say we want to figure out
what is the shape of the V use multiple
rail you units and then figure out how
it actually works so it is just a
generalization of value so now that we
have the basic building blocks of neural
networks let's see how we can learn
using the neural network models yeah so
there is a concept called back
propagation which helps the neural
network model to learn and this is it
yeah so this is a lot of math right we
do not want to go there and figure out
what so I'll just subtract the math part
and tie
to explain how it actually work so what
happens in a feed-forward neural network
is to have inputs and every input is
connected to the hidden layers in the
front and these connections are will be
assigned weights so the input to the
hidden layer will be the input on the
weights so when you start the neural
network model the weights are randomly
assigned and then you start your
computation and this hidden layer can do
any sort of activation from it can be a
sigmoid or tan h or value so it will use
the weights so it multiplied the weights
and the input and some all of them and
give you the output so what actually
happens is let us take this example we
have two inputs we have a hidden layer
and we have an output yeah so initially
we have random weights w1 w 11 w 12 w 13
yeah and they are randomly assigned and
then you simply run one feed one forward
pass of it and then you get an output
which is y hat yeah and obviously this
is erroneous because the weights are
randomly assign so we have an error
which is e which is the difference
between the actual and whatever we have
got now and our job is now to minimize
this error so how do we do this anyone
wants to answer
sorry different shape the French yeah
your differentiate Yeah Yeah right okay
okay now I'm like what do you like yes
you differentiate but why you're
differentiating so how do you go do you
start from this x1 x2 or you do
something else what do you do right so
what you try to do is you have the error
so I'll simplify it a bit and try to
explain it so you have the error what
you do is to fix this error you adjust
the weights in the previous connection
here so you make w21 as W to one bar and
how much you have to adjust depends on
your gradient descent yeah so that is
exactly what he was referring to you
differentiate and you know how much of
w1 w2 one you have to change so that
your error is minimized here and when
you do that step obviously we'll have to
fix your first layer as well so what you
do is you go back one more layer and
then fix the weights for them too so w11
will become w12 etc so this entire thing
of one forward pass and backward pass is
called an epoch and this is where the
actual learning happens so after one
epoch you know what you do one round of
Correction and you run the epoch for
multiple times let's say 10 or 100
depending on the problem and this is how
it actually works so this is all about
learning in neural network this is the
back propagation algorithm there is a
lot of math involved to it but the our
interest is not that today so let's want
so basically what you do is you compute
the gradient the loss function and you
brought back propagate fix the weights
in the previous connection and then you
run it multiple things how many of you
here were present for the pinning pong
hey I think I was happening yeah he was
talking to you guys about using mini
batch and gradient descent so internally
what the neural network was doing was
whenever the ball used to miss the bar
it knew that that was an error and
learning was how do you adjust the
weights for the movement so that it
starts getting a positive score so
that's what he was talking about the
loss function and how the weights get
adjusted the weights get adjusted
through back propagation yeah and to do
that you need to do gradient the same so
let's say this is our error function we
are on the top we need to minimize it so
it can be of different types let's say
it's a hill and valley approach there
might be multiple depending on where you
stand and you where you start to descend
you can go to different directions and
end up at different places right so
gradient decide helps us do that and the
problem is you never know if you
actually go to the what the most part of
the valley there are different there is
a concept called as local minima where
you don't know if that is actually the
minimum the global minimum you get into
this pit and you think that is the
minimum but actually there is a
different minimum at the global scope
and yeah gradient descent was what we
use but then you can to use gradient
descent you will have to use the entire
data set I know in case if you are doing
an image classification or something you
cannot fit them all into your ramen
memory so what you do is you take
batches of them you take let us say 100
or 32 or 64 at once you batch them and
then you do a gradient descent on them
so I take first 64 set of data I do a
gradient descent I take the next 64
again to a gradient descent so this is
called stochastic gradient descent or
mini patch and when the batch size is
one it is called
online learning so yeah so let us go to
multi-layer perceptron so in a
multi-layer perceptron this is a
feed-forward neural network you have
multiple inputs you have you can have
multiple hidden layers here and then you
have an output and generally a sigmoid
activation function is used in
multi-layer perceptron ok I think before
we proceed further how many of you are
on the same page and you have any
questions of you can you can ask away
yeah are we good like do we
but then you might choose another course
bunch of risk yeah
it again depends you will generally be
try out different cost function sine
figure out so what works best for you
might not work the same for others and
the problem you are solving so need to
actually try it out ya know the nodes
okay so that you know what the inputs
are right the nodes that you actually
choose and build other hidden layers in
the hidden layer so in the hidden layers
is where your activation function works
and you configure it so you can have
multiple hidden layers and each hidden
layer is of one single activation
function type so we'll have a
mix-and-match mixin one hidden layer
will have all of them a sigmoid or rail
you the other one could probably have a
perceptron or a tonnage so you can have
multiple layers of hidden layer and each
of them have multiple neurons in them
and in one hidden layer there's one
single activation function so it's your
problem defines how much of nodes you
need in a hidden layer there are some I
wouldn't say standards are some hidden
layers that people follow of how big the
hidden layer should be the biggest
problem with having more than X number
of nodes as the computing capability
because you are as the moment you add
more and more nodes your computational
time starts going so you need to really
know what you are trying to solve and
what your hidden layer is actually doing
yeah
so the input can be anything it depends
on your problem it so it can be your
image classification so your input yeah
it can be anything so let's say we will
actually do a hands-on and maybe you'll
understand it better so we will take a
data set from kagal the auto data set
where you have 90 s three features and
you have one target or label field so
you feed all the 93 as input so you have
93 nodes there as input it can be any I
need not so your type defines yeah yeah
it can be a real gonna be around I guess
yeah yeah yeah
single-layer know okay so this is not an
advantage so what we are trying to show
here is there are multiple hidden layers
and then there's so yeah this is just an
example but depending on your problem
you can have single output or multiple
output if your problem is a binary
classification then a single output will
just do for you but if you have won t
class problem then your output will be
multiple nodes here not just one
so yeah so there it is just one single
logistic function right but here you
have that's a softmax aya okay so what
actually happens is your outputs are
different so the dimension of your
output is different so in terms of like
if you would build this neural network
to do a multi-class let us take a simple
problem so if you are given a name and
you want to figure out the gender for
the name its binary classification it's
yes it's male or female but if you were
to do a multi-class given an object I
want to figure out what it is you would
still be using an activation function
that is a sigmoid but you your outcome
will not be one single Jordan so in
terms of programming the one that you
have output is called as a dense layer
you're dense layer would essentially not
be just one now I don't know if I
answered your question though maybe we
can take yeah you can take it out yeah
yeah
yep I its nonlinear yeah okay so any
other questions we move forward okay so
all of you have the set up ready with
you have you clone the repository yes is
there anyone who have issues going yup
so once you install clone the repository
the prerequisite is you need anaconda
and once you've installed anaconda you
will have to do a pip install Karis so
unless you have Kerris so you not be
able to run the hands-on
how many of you here do not have
anaconda installed okay okay so for
people who have an account is all you
have to do is pip install carers kera is
Karis it caresses a package that
internally uses Tiano as its back end
and the beauty of Charis Azure if you
don't want to use theatre and you want
to use tensorflow you could still do
that so it's an abstraction layer over
what back-end you can use so you can
just specify what your back-end is see I
know our tensorflow and then you can
just use so people who have used
scikit-learn before Kellis is very
similar to that for deep learning
so let's open the I think you'll have to
open the data folder and unzip the photo
dot tired orgy said so on tar it and
unzip it you get the data set and once
you have unzipped it then you can run
the notebook and then come back to
multi-layer perceptron notebook yeah
does anyone have problem or do we just
continue okay let us continue so we have
the multi-layer perceptron here so we do
a bunch of imports here we use scare us
and we are using the auto data set from
kagal we read the train and test data
and this is how the data set is this is
anonymized data we have 93 features and
then a target which is basically your
class of product so is it class 1 class
to class 3 and there are nine classes
and we have 61,000 rose and we need to
convert the target column here in the
data frame to a categorical format we
just do that then we create a new label
column using the categorical one so now
I do not have class 1 plus 2 rather I
have one two three four so that I can
feed it into the multi-layer perceptron
el build so the class numbers are 0 to 8
I just drop the ID column and do some
stuff there so now i have the Y integer
here so what I do is Karis as a utility
function which will convert that into
categorical data which is of this shape
it will basically do a one what encoding
it will expand it into nine columns
which will have zeros and ones there and
here is where we build the multi-layer
perceptron so this is a sequential model
where we place different layers one
after the other so model is equal to
sequential which is coming from carers
and then i say i'll add a dense layer
with output dimension 64 input dimension
is 93 which is X shape of one and then I
have an activation function of tan h tan
x is basically will give you minus 1 or
1 and then I again add one more dense
function and activation here is soft max
because now we this is a multi-class
problem we have soft max we compile it
we define the last function here because
it is a categorical value we have
categorical cross entropy and our
optimizer is a simple SGD and once we
have all these things we compile the
model and fit the model with our
training data which is x and y and here
NBR score epoch will tell you how many
epochs should I run this for so one
epoch is as I told you one forward and
backward pass so we do five of that and
to do stochastic gradient descent the
batch size is 128 and then we just run
it
oh if you see the first one itself gives
you accuracy of a point 64 and then as
and when the epoch increases the
accuracy keeps increasing this is
because whenever an epoch happens there
is more learning and there are more
correction to the weight and it goes
closer to reality now we can go back and
increase the number of epochs or change
the dimension there you can change the
batch size you can change the epoch and
try it around so for people who are
trying it here you can just change this
value sign point
yeah so from 5 we make it 10 and then
run it
you see that the accuracy keep
increasing but after a point we'll hit
threshold line will not increase so you
can just play it around play around
later and it can work okay so how many
of you actually ran this oh no possible
the road books of Stanford itself and
this was just a small demonstration to
show how MLP works I think if you guys
can't compile it or run it here you can
always go back and install the required
packages and run them and if there's
anything you can always try to as to I
understand what they do with that we
continue yeah do any of you have
questions here
for the dance okay here oh here right so
I wanted 64 notes in the next hidden
layer so I just it's a random value I
here and it worked for me yeah just from
there which looks to be like maxing out
yeah regard even got to the leaderboard
in terms of what was actually achieved
on this problem do you know sorry where
does it sit roughly on the lead on this
oh oh we never we never pushed we have
not submitted it oh yeah we had
submitted it yeah we just took the data
session and then we ran it now but a lot
of people are already using carers for
this and I think the creator of Charis
he himself has posted a lot of code
using this package and I think the one
that sitting on top of the leaderboard
is a one symbol of machine learning
models more than deep learning yeah yeah
yeah um oh this one accuracy the
different matrix so you can just refer
to the package Charis you can go to care
estate I oh and we'll give you what are
the metrics you want as output so this
matrix just tells you what is output you
want for us we need accuracy and that is
where it is telling you this is the loss
and accuracy so it can try out different
things there okay so one thing is after
you run a lot of epochs the models
accuracy does not increase and there's
something called as callbacks and it
usually if your value loss is like it's
not changing after a point in time even
if you've given more than 100 epochs it
stops after it things don't change so
the only idea here was to for us to
start seeing accuracy so that we know
how good the model is after you run
X number of epochs and the multiple
metrics that you can pass into them yeah
we move to the next one yeah anything
else lyrics okay so one thing one
problem with artificial neural networks
is too quickly over fit when you have
small amount of data so if you have
hundreds or thousands of data there is a
high chance that you will be over
fitting and there are some ways how you
can work um this in artificial neural
network you can do a weight DK or l1 l2
regularization or the famous one is drop
out so one of the artificial neural
networks is there for a long time but
then from 2010 it has been picked up
like crazy and the reason is off drop
the reason is the invention of dropout
so draw what happens in drop out is you
have all these connections and when you
are training the model you randomly
remove the weights and when you randomly
remove the weights and run it people
have observed that you it is not our
fitting and it actually works accurately
and there is no reason actually why this
thing would stop port works Geoffrey
Hinton the father of deep flirting he
actually says Robert works but there is
no reason with work and that is active
area of research yeah now it's randomly
removing it just randomly removing the
one so and then the others the remaining
connections are just telling it because
it's a once you randomly remove and
there's a back and forward pass and then
there's an error you again reassign
realign the weights yeah yeah
yeah oh um someone else had a question
okay okay now we move on to natural
language processing yeah okay so before
I start talking about natural language
passing and get into deep learning how
many of you here have done natural
language processing before Wow okay uh
what were you guys doing I mean uh what
did you use and anymore NLT k and l TK
yeah sorry okay okay okay yeah okay okay
anyone else did anything up apart from
the library's what were you actually
using it for and what kind of approaches
were you looking at okay so I'll go
ahead and I'll start talking about what
are the different approaches for natural
language processing before we get into
how deep learning is used oh okay how
many of you would be amazed if you could
have a machine cough up new recipes
a-and but the problem here is if you if
you actually look into this it says cut
the beer into cubes right I mean a
machine would generate a recipe no doubt
but the problem is does the machine
understand what is the idea behind this
generation and what is the essence
behind it so before we get into
understanding how this works let's take
a simpler normal approach so current NLP
or mostly what people do with natural
language processing is you have your
input and then you extract your features
which is term frequency in your x
inverse document frequency or you do a
bag of words up
Roach and then you have a machine
learning model which is your soft max or
your support vector machine and you
start predicting how good the modulus
but if you really work with natural
language processing the biggest problem
is you're expecting input to be right in
the sense how many of you here have used
when and Martin or no water and Michael
is ok so what an in Martin act is a book
which gives you the rules for it's
basically a grammar rules and the
biggest problem with natural language
processing is you are expecting the
input to be grammatically right you are
expecting the words to be present in the
right position but if you're solving a
real problem that is not how it works
you have a sentence and sentence has non
phrases verbs adjectives everything put
together but in this world if you are if
you see most of the Facebook post or
Twitter which allows you only to use 140
characters you see that people have
started using short forms of words and
people are not really caring if the
words grammatically right and when you
are trying to do any social media
analytics are reading blog posts you are
assuming it to be right and your model
assumes the same and things break so
structure is very important but it's
very hard to know that the structure is
right like for example a small crowd
quietly enters the historic church is
not the same as a historic crowd enters
and small charge it's just the moment of
two words and the whole context changes
and how many of you know what sarcasm is
eight and if you are solving anything
related to sarcasm it's very hard to
capture any sarcasm even for humans the
lots of people who can't capture
sometimes I can't either but so simple
thing is representing structure is hard
representing shock
sure is very hard because your
vocabulary is big and your vocabulary
keeps changing like 20 years back people
probably spoke a different dialect of
English than most of us do because our
English mixed up with a lot of technical
words and our words the don't even exist
like for example if I am talking about a
scalable system scalable is not actually
a word that's an the Oxford Dictionary
right and so over time your words your
engram starts exploding and
representation of structure starts
becoming harder and harder so we have a
lot of limitations with the current
current architecture for doing natural
language processing that's widely
followed and people are changing now the
thing is you have fixed sizes of input
and then you're fixed computational
steps and you would see that two three
years back the only thing people are
trying to do as they were trying to
build rules and see who is an actor and
try to find a whole lot of relations
with the actor itself and again that's
are becoming a very big problem because
your engram side exploring and you
didn't really understand context now
before I go further and see how we can
solve this step-by-step any idea how
this can be solved how do you solve or
understand structure without the
structure not really being present I'm
sorry all right
okay before we go so deep into the new
simple what can we do that is a more
simpler approach of yeah
like a co-occurrence matrix
co-occurrence matrix yeah that's one we
any other okay um there's no one single
solution then ever is we are there's one
way of solving this and this is called
as vectorization how many of you here
know what vectorization actually means
okay um what what is vectorization the
ones who know I'm sorry vectorization in
general when really generally what is
yeah so exactly so your turn information
to a vector precisely so you here in
natural language processing is your
converting text into numbers because
computers understand numbers better and
they're different ways of doing it one
is called as one hot encoding the other
ones so what you do with one heart
encoding is you take the position the
index of the word and you just encoded
based on however bigger the dimension
you're looking at how many of you here
have used wordnet fuse natural language
yeah okay so wordnet is this huge
library where previously I don't know if
lots of people are using I think they
are what you could if you gave wordnet a
word it would give out all the synonyms
for the word and there are so many
different things in wordnet where every
day it's getting updated and it's like a
huge dictionary with reverse mapping for
different things now do you see a
challenge in maintaining were denied
what would be the challenge if you had a
huge dicks yeah
yeah and maintaining this manually is is
a pain right and and then there is
co-occurrence matrix as he mentioned
where if there is a presence of one word
with the other word then you say how how
good is the co-occurrence of let us say
food and let's say pizza if if there's a
sentence with food and pizza coming all
the time the co-occurrence of pizza with
food would be very high but at some
point of time these things fail mainly
because in one heart you're really not
considering the context the context of
using words with different sentences
mean completely differently and wordnet
really hard to handle because someone
has to manually go update and change
relations and over time nothing manual
manual things break and the
co-occurrence matrix the biggest problem
is if you have a billion words then it's
a billion cross billion co-occurrence
matrix and even if you have to change a
value of one single word co-occurring
with the other though the computation is
very high so we okay so be overcome this
with a concept called as word to whack
any of you heard of this before Wow
awesome okay so yeah so this was
something that was released by Jeff in
2010 by Google and what they are
essentially trying to do is they do a
window based vectorization where they
are vectorizing a word if I may by
considering the words around that
particular word and the words vector
keeps changing based on different places
it occurs so what you are solve with
this which was lacking in most of them
was here you do not really care about
grammar you don't care if the structure
is right because you're not really
passing it against a structure you are
just giving the emphasis for the word
and the presence of other words around
it and based on the surrounding words
the model starts learning and picking up
vocabulary so you do not really need
training data for something for the
model to run the more
starts learning by using the data that
is given and different domains have
different data set so whatever data you
feed into the model the model starts
learning the language and at any given
point of time one vector represents the
discrete state of the word right and so
similar words are glued together so done
so this was something that they didn't
anticipate would happen with
vectorization with word to wake approach
so when they tried to solve this problem
of when you searched something on Google
and they wanted to give you searches
that meant closest to what you searched
for and the biggest problem with that is
whenever we search on Google the problem
is we don't really search with grammar
so structure was becoming really hard
for them to understand so they wanted to
try and see if you had words and when
you vectorize them with windows do the
same words sit together and they realize
afterward to why can they ran a lot of
operations they realized that most of
similar words are clustered together so
how many of you have an android phone
and how many of you like the next word
prediction there it is actually built on
top of what the white to whack yeah so
so it is reading your context that
you've typed before and it predicts what
the next value so it does it with two
different it can predict in two
different ways one is called as a skip
Graham where if you take the context
word which is learning it vector eyeses
learning based on a window of context
around it that as it would consider an
efficient method fall and high quality
distributed vector and it will vectorize
learning in this statement based on
those surrounding words this is one
approach so given learning so the
outcome of this approach is given the
word learning it will predict the
surrounding words around it right and
the next one is called as continuous bag
of words where instead of trying to give
a context word you try to give a set of
words around a particular word and you
want to try NC
if it can predict what you are looking
for and if you are interested in
automating email like sending of emails
or writing emails this is wonderful
because if you're pissed off at your
boss and you want to use diplomatic
words and you cannot really find any you
can type a statement build a model and
you can give the back of words to the
model i'll tell you what is the work
that you can probably use a yeah that's
awesome and this is one way of doing it
so this is both of them looking both of
the models next to each other so in your
continuous bag-of-words approach you're
trying to predict a word based on a set
of words and in skip Graham given a word
or based on the words around it you you
predict the words around it yeah so I
think we've taken a very interesting
data set to show the power of word to
whack if you can yeah so go back to the
little notebook kind yeah sorry yeah
yep yeah okay so in an Engram approach
what you are still trying to do is
you're going one word after the other
and you have n grams next to it but
you're not really taking the whole
around the boundary around it like you
are not taking its neighbors on the left
and on the right one secondly when you
take an Engram approach not really doing
vectorization you're not representing a
word by the words present around it with
Engram what you are really trying to do
is you're jumping your windows in a
trying to see if something makes sense
so if you were if you've ever done
entity extraction or if you and you
would basically have past acts for a
word which is the structure of the
statement which is parts of speech and
then you would slide your window to see
which is you are now named entity and
what are your verbs but the problem
there again is structure so this
bypasses structure because it's learning
based on the data that it's given
without really caring what language it
is and this is what the power behind
this and other amazing thing is no
matter which language you use if you are
trying to translate a statement from
English let's say Spanish because the
words are supposed to relate it to each
other in based on the words surrounding
it you can actually get the Spanish word
for whatever you mentioned in English
they'd all be sitting together in the
same cluster so that is the beauty of
what do it because you're vectorizing
based on the surrounding words of any
other questions yeah
difficulty figuring out what represents
so is it so for example is it for
learning yeah dimensions yeah so what it
does is if you take learning so when it
comes across learning for the first time
based on the words around learning it
would have built a vector the second
time it comes across the word learning
it looks at the words around it and it
sees what has changed and what has not
so slowly if you have a bigger corpus
then you will see that learning is
vector is based on the presence of
different words that come next to it so
basically try to get the probability
given the current word is learning what
could be the surrounding words you find
the probability of that so you define
the dimension of the vector so you can
say I'm looking at I care I only care
about five words before this before my
context were and five words or two
things one is the window size and the
Diamonds well you can define you can
define it yeah yeah yeahs science okay
okay
a network and after training you have to
do this 100 dimensions but different
white support for Stanford at work yeah
how do you just look for his neighbor oh
so you are so you do something called as
dist cosine distance where you have
based on this since you just find which
is finding the ones that are closest to
it because everything's a vector so
cause of 0 is 1 so the distance between
two way because you're representing
vectors the distance between two vectors
if they are minimum the the distance is
minimum then you are they are more
similar to each other and because the
each vector is in state is a discrete
state that it represents of that
particular word you see that similar
words our group together because your
vectors look similar and because you
have a higher dimension let's say 100 a
word can have different states so let's
say of a word bank bank can be your
river bank bank can be your institution
bank or it might be a sentence sentence
where I say I am banking on you so bank
has different meanings to it and because
you're in a higher dimension this word
is now can be represented in different
formats and in each dimension it has a
probability of going with the next word
so basically when this entire window
based vectorization happens it actually
learns the relation between the words to
yeah yeah yeah you take the context of
both of them the work the words before
and that's your window right so taking
both your vectors for both of them and
then you predict the next one so if you
take if you look at the continuous bag
of words you are different words and it
took vectors of all of them summed it up
together and in your lower vector
summation it gives you the closest
vector that it matches to for that sum
vector it again depends on what what
what is you have water Cavalier you have
any other question we can move on to
hands-on okay I think we'll just quickly
move through the hands on you we still
have to show deep learning because yeah
okay there's another library that you
guys have to install it's called as
Jensen and it's why i think it is part
of anaconda yeah okay yeah if it's part
of an account is awesome because it's a
very good library to do word to work we
just I think we just shown through okay
so how many of you here know
Shakespeare's plays Julius Caesar and
Mark with no not by I may have heard of
yeah okay so we've taken a Julius Caesar
and Mac bit of we download this from
Gutenberg Gutenberg and then we are
trying to make sense of characters
without there is no training data the
data are these two plays and we're
trying to see if we can find relations
between characters or characters as in
characters in the play or characters in
the play i'm sorry/not alphabet
characters here so we just laying the
data set we do a bunch of cleaning yeah
they remove the stop words
so keys are the sentences there okay so
what we're doing here is a building a
word to make model and we are providing
the corpus of the sentences of from both
Julius Caesar and Mark pit and we say
when we are telling that retain the
context of words of just length of five
windows a length of five and sizes of
that's the dimension and we have four
workers so they can run in parallel and
the minimum count is our when you
consider the window i'm giving a
frequency that this word has to occur at
least five times so that's the parameter
so basically this is the vocabulary the
model has now so one has occurred more
than five times so it sits in the
vocabulary yeah okay how many of you
here know what TS any is ok so for for
others what DSN is trying to do is
because we have represented a word in
500 dimensions you cannot really
visualize something and how many of you
can visualize beyond three dimensions
and plot it on a kind of ironic okay
yeah I can't I can't two dimensions hard
for me so three dimensions like really
really hard so what TSN he does is it is
a dimension reduction ality and it
reduces from your ex dimensions that you
have to something that you can represent
in a two-dimensional plane so what we
are trying to do here with the TS any
model is are we are trying to represent
a 500 dimension vector and try to see if
there are words that are similar to each
other that can be represented in two
dimensions as it should yeah okay so
this is okay so this is our model and
this is how it's understood so I don't
know how much so it sees that bed and
speak or words that sit next to each
other and there is a dishonest and
there's while
that are very close to each other based
on what are the data that we fed looking
at this it's just trying to see if the
words are grouped together but the real
power comes next when you can do
analogies so how many of you know which
character belongs to which play because
Duncan is belongs to is a king is a Duke
of Scotland and Caesar Caesar so what we
are trying to see here with this analogy
is if Duncan is to Scotland Caesar as to
which place and prior to this we've
never mentioned any rules we have not
fabricated the data to show results and
just based on the vocabulary that it's
learned it's trying to build relations
based on the words presence you see that
we were actually the way it's understood
relation is Duncan is related to
Scotland it says Caesar is as related to
Brutus right and if you look at so I
think Duncan was killed by max width I
know so Duncan and Mac bet were related
you know in a way and we're trying to
see who Caesar is related to so Caesar
is related most to Lord so a lot of
people are calling him the Lord and then
the very next that Caesar is related to
his Brutus right and we are trying to
see the same with another cat called his
bank oh right so these are analogies so
this was something that people never
really realized when they built were to
work because this was what this was not
what word to wake was built for and this
was like a site product which even
amazed the people who built this and so
though so if you look at the last
statement mod so we at what we are
trying to say is if we give five
forwards or X words what is the word
that does not belong to the context of
words that we give so duncan mac with
bank lowered characters and scotland's a
place it's able to understand that
scotland is being used as a something
else considering the other three of them
one thing that we can show is we've
taken our window size of five something
that you can guys can go back and
is if you take bigger windows bigger
dimension representation how do your
analogies look like and if you start
looking into the articles that are
written one beautiful analogy if you
give it wikipedia corpus or Google
billion token corpuses if you give if
man is to King what is women too and
it's a is Queen and there's absolutely
no training and it learns based on the
positioning of the words and the context
behind it yeah there every position suit
in the exact same way no it doesn't it's
not caring about structure so that's the
beauty so even if you miss words but if
you're representing them in a slang way
it still doesn't matter because it's not
looking at structure it's vectorizing
based on something that's present around
it and that's how its able to pick
relations and also you don't need
something like wordnet yeah you keep on
adding words you can have your own
dictionary because a financial language
might be difficult dine technology or a
normal English so it's very hard to have
werden it there but if you use something
like this you just feed the data and
then you have already built the
relations I have any other questions
because we still have deep learning to
show okay so another thing with water is
this is shallow network because it has
one single layer it with one one single
neural network layer and it's already
being widely used and if you can go back
and check you'll see lots of usage and
people are trying to do a lot of
wonderful things with word to work if
there is anything else that you want to
talk about what to work or NLP thing we
can probably take it off and I think
probably have 20 more minutes will do
the tip so now we go back to neil
networks the recurrent neural network so
whatever you we have seen till now is
only feed forward neural network so we
saw data moving from left to right and
there is no loop anywhere
so this is what we saw right that was
horizontal is vertical it is just one
way of movement and there is no feedback
but then there might be interaction
between the hidden layers here or there
might be a feedback loop here from the
hidden layers so this is called
recurrent neural network the only thing
special here is there is interaction in
between the layer itself the hidden
layer and there can be interaction
across the layer so this is one too many
sequence where you have an image and you
want to explain what it is so you give
it an input you give an image and you
want to find out what are the objects in
the image yeah and then you can have
many to one sequence where you give
multiple input and then you want one
output to do sentiment analysis or you
can have many to many like initials
suggested you can have a machine
translation where you have english to
spanish translation so how many of you
have used the Google Translate app yeah
it's wonderful so all you have to do is
so open the app and show up bold or
something which is in Spanish it
automatically converts the text on the
flight to English and that is only that
is made possible only because of neural
networks and the cranial networks
basically this is the structure of
recurrent urinary RNN you have an input
X you have a single node there is a
feedback here and then you have an
output so it is nothing but you you can
easily unroll it and say there is the
same thing but over time it is just
moving forward so the input of the
second one will be the output of the
last one over time you get the input
from the previous pass on to the next
one so this is about recurrent neural
network sign there is one special kind
of recurrent neural network
called a long short term memory lstm so
the problem with recurrent neural
network is let us say you have a movie
going on and there is some amount of
information which was not just there
three or four words before but it was
specified in the start of the movie
let's say a character Duncan Duncan is a
male and then you want to use the next
word it should it be he or she you don't
know that depends on the gender there so
that is that cannot be done with a
simple recurrent neural network there
were problems because there is no memory
there yeah it just gets the output from
the previous layer then they figured out
you can have something called as a lstm
layer where you have a memory layer
inside every node so what this does is
it might look complicated but then it is
fairly simple there are three parts to
it the first line here then the middle
part here and then the output here so
how many of you know what gates are or I
and 99 or X or so that's precisely what
it's doing so it is basically
combination of the gates you have and
kind or then we use our activation
functions sigmoid tonics etc and then
each cell here each node has a cell
state so what this does is the layer on
top the line going there will help us to
maintain the memory so that contours how
much of information and how much of
memory should be passed on to the next
cell so you can have your gender
information always running through all
the cells so that you know Duncan is ma
and the next word should be he and in
Spanish equivalent of e there is
something so you can retain your
knowledge using the sense state here so
there are three parts the first one is
the forget layer here you have the
output coming in from the law
sellstate last cell node you have the
input new input and then you run a
sigmoid activation and now this and the
output from this will control how much
of the previous and state should I
remember to move forward so if it is a 1
you will remember everything from the
previous cell stay if it is zero you
don't remember anything and because this
is a sigma you can partially remember
some of them so so for example the
gender information so there is always a
cell state going so there are two output
one is HD but there is also an output
which is the cell state itself the
output of all the combination of these
encoded in what sense encoding the sense
how is the gender and oh so it's a it's
only so it's the number salam but
basically a vector everywhere so
everything is vectorized so before you
feed it into a neural network model the
first layer will be an embedding layer
which is nothing but vectorizing your
inputs these yeah they are vectors so
that is the forget layer which controls
how much of information from the
previous cell state you want to remember
and this is the major computation layer
we're given the new input what is the
new cell state that is computed here we
have the new input then you run sigmoid
then at an itch then you combine it with
the previous estate to give the new cell
state here and after this now you have
an output you have a cell state and then
you give a combination of them to the
next one so basically you have a long
memory lowing showing everywhere oh yeah
so the problem with RNN is if you have a
very small data set then you do not get
a good generalization and will end up
over fitting or you do not have good
results so for you to have good results
you should have the recommended is
million by google but then not all of us
will have such a big data set at least
tenth of tens of thousands of data
points is what is recommended not just
1000 or 2000 when you have smaller data
set you don't really get good accuracy
so let's just run through the notebooks
for this because I have a laptop v we
had to choose a smaller data set we have
a set of a block data set where we have
labels male author and female author we
will try to use lstm mind do a
classification on them we have around
3000 data points three thousand blogs or
combination of male and female so let's
see how it works so do we read the data
set we do a bunch of cleaning as usual
yeah we do a filtration there remove
stop words etc then we create labels for
them so for me zero is male and one is
female so I create a new label column
and what we do is for lstm to run it is
not based on words but it starts from
single character so it is very similar
to how a baby learn so to speak it will
start uttering simple syllables and then
simple words then it will actually form
proper sentences so we are doing the
same thing here we have skin escala yeah
so what we are doing is we build a
dictionary of character to index
dictionary and index to character
dictionary so given a character let us
say a I know the index of it and the
reverse mapping as forgiving one I know
it is a similarly we do the same thing
for labels as well a dictionary of
flavors here it is very simple because
we just have two labels two classes of
flavors male or female but then you can
have a multi-class problem where you
have nine or ten and you need an index
for that for the reverse mapping as well
so we say that the maximum length we
will consider is 5000 from a blog we are
defining it here and this method here is
converting every block to a sequence of
character which will basically give us
the indexes which will be input for the
lstm near so now we have x and y which
is nothing but the character indices
character sequence index and then we
have the labels here now we run a simple
lstm model again it is a sequential one
we place the layers next to each other
here is the embedding layer where we do
the vectorization yeah and we define the
maximum length
and we add an lstm layer here where the
input size is 32 then we have a dropout
layer to do some regularization and then
a dense layer of size one because I just
need to know is it a male or female
which is Sigma optimized activation I
compile the model and then give the test
and training data there justice will
take away so this will take a while lstm
is computation heavy and it takes a lot
of time actually when you have medium
set of data it will actually run for our
kind here you can see it is running so
it says one epoch will take 1 90 seconds
approximately and we have said we need
10 epochs so 190 into ten nineteen
hundred seconds that's one we get kicked
out so so with this running what we do
is we'll go back to the slides okay
before we go back any questions yeah
okay yeah so if some yeah someone's
using Python 3 to work with water back
you need to do some tweaks to get the
whole library up and yeah yeah yeah
right yeah yeah thank you sorry yeah so
if you're using Python 3 and if using
word to whack cell number 30 using of
okay we can go back so we are using
Python 2 so if you are using Python 3
you will have to adapt to python 3
you'll have to do some modification in
cell number 30 30 yeah yeah yeah yeah so
yeah get it yeah yeah so this filter
function is differently it's represented
different in Python Python 3 using
yeah yeah yeah any other questions on
LST a modern n before we go ahead yeah
it depends like for example sometimes
stop words are important based on what
problem you are trying to solve but here
what we are trying to do with the
different blogs is we are considering
stop words don't really add value but it
actually might because different people
might probably be using stop words in a
completely different way the reason
we've removed it as we thought we clean
it and just concentrate on feature words
that are non stop and try to classify
the gender otherwise it depends on what
problem you are trying to solve yeah
yeah okay so r NN like any other neural
network the problem is it you have to
let the model learn the words you give
it characters so it comes from bottom up
bottom right to fix the characters get
into words words to get into sentences
sentences into a blogger blog so using
Ella stream you can actually give a good
amount of data set let us say you have
30,000 blogs and then ask the lstm model
to generate blog for you so that is also
possible so initially it will start
outputting random characters you can
have a dot exclamation here / be coming
then after let's say many boats or yeah
run it for whaling upon how powerful
your computer design the data set the
output starts getting vector so it
learns like a small kid that's the
notion behind
any other questions we have one small
topic remaining the power GPUs so all of
them need a lot of computation power and
then people have realized that what
matters is the flop cycle the float
operation cycle and it happens that GPUs
are very good in processing floating
numbers and cuda in media team has come
up with cuda which helps you fastin your
deep learning process so even on AWS now
you get head of these instances powered
by GPU so that you can you can do all
the deep learning stuff on the cloud how
many of you played games on your
computer like a or you played games with
or without seen GPU I am sure that you
would have seen a remarkable difference
in the graphics yeah so yeah so CPU is
Paul but then GPU is focused on doing
Computing's and intensive tasks it has a
lot more course than a single CPU would
have so that is the reason people are
now using multiple GP or GPU clusters to
do deep learning yeah I know this is one
way of doing things but there are also
different kinds of hardware you can use
there is something called as a
neuromorphic engineering research where
based on the problem you are trying to
solve you come up with a custom hardware
with all the neuron design and that is
much faster and it uses less amount of
energy comparatively but then the plus
point here with Jeep uses it is a
generic device you can run any kind of
you can solve any kind of problem you
want but then the neuromorphic
engineering is more specific to your
problem and that is an active area of
research going on I think the building
some machines and Stanford reserve
the idea is with all of this your till
you're still trying to simulate how
human brain works but the attempt they
are trying to make with neuromorphic
poses are trying to emulate a human mind
I now they're trying to bring down the
power consumption as much as possible by
delivering more speed computational
speed and some examples of deep learning
our video classification you are in
YouTube how many of you have used the
auto caption so basically that runs on
neural networks so the input is a audio
stream and then it detects the text what
is the text of the audio and then it
gives you the caption and now the
caption can be of any language can be
English it can be Spanish or Hindi it
can be anything an image recognition a
lot of fashion commerce site are now
using image recognition to do better
recommendation systems so you come up
with better I can i buy a blue shirt
what kind of pine should I buy so those
are the things people are building now
and this is one famous example image
generation by Google inception ISM you
feed it a lot of paintings and images
and then ask the model to paint it on
itself and this is what you get out of
that then you can also do a handwriting
generation yeah so there are endless
amount of application there and I all
these slides everything will be
available on the repository we'll just
pair somewhere it's there on speaker
deck and with all the code is on github
any questions yeah ok we're done
any questions um yeah yeah here's a
question yes I weakness off out ended up
so the thing with rns it's based on
neural networks you can have a better
solution for your nonlinear problems but
the only problem with RNN is it cannot
remove remember memory and that was
solved using lstm and there is one more
concept called as GRU gated value unit